it's time for dear drew
and we have a very special guest joining
us today he is known for playing kevin g
the rapping mathlete mean girls and he's
also made a name for himself on
instagram displaying his calligraphy art
with pen pals he has all around the
country
please welcome the creator of letters in
ink rajiv surendra
[Applause]
we
here at dear drew usually start the
segment with um we call it the zip code
of the day
and today's zip code is 27606
raleigh north carolina
that's right
and it is home of our affiliate station
w r a z fox 50. home to more than 40
free historic attractions and museums
raleigh is also known as the smithsonian
of the south that's cool from paintings
to pints the rally beer garden in the
guinness book of world records has the
largest selection of beers on tap with
over 360 to choose from cheers
cheers to you raleigh north carolina we
would love to hear from you please write
us a letter
[Applause]
all right
let's open our first letter oh this is
more than a letter
oh
i am loving this already i'm a tie-dye
sock enthusiast this person gets me they
know me dear drew i couldn't think of
anyone that loves flowers as much as i
do besides you enclosed are a few items
that have been naturally dyed using
flowers and botanicals that i make and
sell online at michellemoredesigns.com
michelle kingston new york
that's so beautiful
okay these are incredible i really am by
the way michelle a huge tie-dye sock
enthusiast and the fact that it came
from flowers is so romantic i mean
wow and we're gonna put your um store on
our website michellemoredesigns.com
so that we can feature you in our little
book of small businesses gift guide
rajiv your letter
hi rajiv i had the greatest pleasure of
discovering your letter writing is not
dead video
there is something truly magical and
sentimental about writing someone a
letter jameel harrison new
that jersey jameel
how um does it feel that this is really
taking off and connecting people i'm so
honored i have been handwriting since i
was a little kid and it turned into
calligraphy the question that i get
asked most often is how do i start to
learn calligraphy will you teach me
something because i've never done it
shall we do a little demo shall i show
you a little something okay
so
we're gonna start by just like a stretch
i want you to move your arms move your
arms
exactly exactly okay now let's take it
to the board
so this is what we're gonna do we're
gonna make ovals but we're gonna make
them on us on a 52 degree slant so watch
me we're just gonna go like this and use
your whole arm
good
so once you've kind of loosened up we're
going to go to our letter forms okay
let's do a d okay so watch me we're
going to start with a stroke that goes
down
i'm gonna make a little loop
i'm gonna go down and then up and down
nice
and now let's put in the r
e
w
nice if you keep practicing let me show
you what it will what it will look like
okay
i'm gonna show you
i ran out of room but
[Applause]
don't look turn around okay um let's
turn around let's do our separate
versions of it
that's my signature look how beautiful
that is oh my god this is so special
all right
we've got one more letter and this one
is from linda from sudbury massachusetts
i wanted to write you to thank you for
developing your show
i'm a 74 year old grandmother who lives
alone
and you brought much comical fun and
happiness to my life ps yellow is my
favorite color too
see by a few pictures of my yellow
belongings
linda sudbury massachusetts
oh look at her beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]
um
i mean
i didn't know what she was gonna say
but we
are gonna actually surprise her on zoom
she thinks she's gonna talk to a
producer from our show but we're gonna
surprise her nice
nice
okay
[Applause]
hello linda are you there
i am hi drew
[Applause]
oh linda you look so beautiful with your
yellow beads and your yellow shirts
wow
oh i'm so happy to meet you
linda
i have this um basket of yellow swag
from our show but um if it's okay you'll
have to come by and get it
so we would love to bring you and
your best girlfriend to a taping of the
show right here in the city and include
you in the show and have you be our
special guests and then afterwards we
want to send you out um to a fabulous
fancy dinner in the city oh and a spa
too
[Applause]
okay michelle linda and jameel thank you
for your letters so much here are our
postcards to you
and we're gonna stick them right here in
the mailbox
truly yours drew and rajiv
[Music]